the summer's hottest party for a
one-year-old yeah it's cardi b and
offsets sun waves at birthday bash
there's some big big things on the way
big bangs cardi takes fans inside the
car theme to celebration on her
instagram story big wave birthday
the first one first one the little one
makes quite the entrance and rides in
style thanks to his aunt hennessy carved
by hennessy
[Applause]
i can't do it
yeah but this might be too cute to
handle
[Music]
and there's plenty to go around for the
special guests like elaborate desserts
car races and some pretty epic food
stations
look at that look at that
oh my god
after leftovers after leftovers
this isn't going to be left over though
meanwhile offset shares a sweet moment
from the hospital when wave was born
[Music]
plus waves big sis culture makes the
party a true family affair
back in july culture was treated to an
equally lavish b-day bash
sometimes i just want to show people how
beautiful and how
precious she is she's so precious
seriously as cardi tells it these
extravagant celebrations aren't just to
show off
as she explains on twitter i know i can
be a little extra when it comes to my
kids but i ain't really had it growing
up so yeah i'm a ball
the cakes get better every year the
four-year-olds under the sea themed
party was a kid's paradise ball pits
bounce houses
[Music]
even some real-life mermaids posing by
the pool
[Music]
hi baby
plus a painting area for culture's
closest pals
from school
yeah she's just she's mental
friends from school
[Music]
there was even a custom beauty bar for
kk's friends so they can match her pink
and blue fishtail braids
cute by the way this is my house with
luxurious parties like these for cardi's
kids we can only have high hopes for
what's to come next year you had a good
time
you had a good time
you did
yeah
are you too cute
[Music]
you